the only child of Loki that I've yet to
cover in a video is the eight-legged
horse Sleipnir the son of Loki and the
stallion svaðilfari a slate neared his
most famous will be in the horse that
Odin rode into battle during Ragnarok as
well as whenever he ventured to the
realm of Hell the horse is mentioned in
both of the Eddas as well as in some of
these sagas that followed it's also
mentioned that he was the best of all
horses which is a fairly vague statement
but one can assume that it refers to he
speed and loyalty now it may seem odd to
say that Loki is sleeping his father
because swaddle Fadi is a stallion a
male horse so technically he has two
fathers but the real question is how
does a male yotan and a male horse have
a child
well loki transformed himself into a
mare and then mated us fuddled fadi
which in turn raises the question why
would loki transform himself into a
female to then have sex with a horse and
give birth to another horse with eight
legs so one day this unnamed builder
arrives in Asgard and tells the gods
that he can build them a huge wall to
protect them from their enemies in
exchange he asked for the goddess
Freya's hand in marriage as well as the
Sun and the moon so you know nothing
major the gods discussed this offer and
after some persuasion from Loki they
decided to accept but only if the
Builder could build the wall in three
seasons the spring summer and autumn
with no assistance from any other man
the Builder then only had one request
that he could use his horse to help him
this horse was the stallion svaðilfari
sleeping his father
as you may have guessed the gods
accepted his request and it turns out
that this is no ordinary stallion as the
Builder began to make progress his
efforts were doubled by his horse and
was able to move twice the amount of
rocks as his master making the
impossible task of complete in the
fortifications before winter quite
possible with a few days left before the
end of autumn the Builder was on track
to finish and so the gods convened to
discuss the issue they concluded that it
was Loki's fault and if he did not find
a way to stop the fortifications being
built then he would be sentenced to a
horrible death that night as the Builder
and his horse continued working
tirelessly a female horse appeared out
of nowhere and swaddled fari began to
give chase the mysterious horse was
indeed Loki in disguise the Builder then
spent the entire evening chasing after
his horse meaning work on the
fortification was delayed
this gave the gods enough time to
realize that the Builder was actually a
yotan and upon this discovery all
promises were broken and Thor was
summoned Thor then does what he does
best he took me on air and smashed the
giant skull to pieces after an evening
of being chased loki then gave birth to
slave near so we can assume that at some
point loki mated of the stallion to
delay the fortifications and to save
himself so sleep Neal was born because
Loki got himself into a situation where
turning into a horse and having sex with
another horse seemed to be the best way
out of it
all of that said loki is fairly
eccentric and definitely doesn't have
the most normal children so let me know
what you think in the comments below as
always I've been your host mythology and
fiction explained
[Music]